So when I was taught as a student, I was taught
by a chemist at Cambridge school Alfie Maddock.
Who during the Second World War was working in Canada
on Plutonium chemistry. And one night he managed
to spill the entire UK's  supply of Plutonium.
Which was only 10 milligrams onto the bench in the lab.
And so rather then saying 'oh dear I have spilt it',
he went and got a saw and sawed a large chunk out of
the bench, and burned the wood, and got back 9.5 of the 10 Mg
that he spilled. And nobody would have known
except at that point, he was too tired to repair
the bench. So they came down  in the morning, and there was
a large hole in the bench, to show what he had done.
Ok so Plutonium. I think Plutonium is quite well known
for the fact its been used in certain types of nuclear bombs.
It's a fairly interesting element, it's incredibly dense.
If you hold a golf ball size shape of Plutonium in your hand,
it would weigh in excess of half a kilogram.
Which is one heavy golf ball. And if you were holding it,
you would have to be holding it through several layers of gloves,
at least one of which would be lead lined.
And as you held it, it would be like having a really hot cup of tea
in your hand. And that's from the radioactivity coming out.
Just the shear heat of the radioactivity which you
would be feeling. I also had an interesting experience
with... At a conference, I was sitting next to a lady, who I asked her
why she was at the conference, which was about
super critical fluids. High pressure gases, solvents.
And I asked her why she was there and she said she worked
with weapons grade Plutonium. What is used in making
Atom Bombs.  And she said she was worried
about the environmental effects of using chlorinated solvents.
There are compounds of Carbon and Chlorine, for removing the greace
from the Plutonium that we are using to make the bombs.
So she was at the conference to see whether you could use
high pressure Carbon Dioxide or as an alternative to
make the making of atomic bombs environmentally friendly.
That was slightly macabre. Worrying about the environment.
I like that, wanting to make more environmentaly friendly bombs.
I have not seen any because the sort of facilities you need to be
able to handle it are way beyond what you find
in a normal university. I've had some fascinating stories
about it, it's incredibly dense. And a few people at the Atomic
Weapons Agency wanted to cut a little piece off,
it took three of them with a  hacksaw several hours,
and several hacksaw blades, before they got a tiny little
chip off. So it's incredibly dense and hard. Hence the high
weight for its size.
Plutonium is quite a poisonous element, and there have been
a number of cases. Particularly the famous case in America,
with Karen Silkwood, who was poisoned, or had traces of poisonous Plutonium
found in her refrigerator, and all through her flat.
Which in fact inspired my brother to write a play called
"Stronger Then The Sun" in the early 1970s. One of his first successful
television films. Perhaps a little known thing
about Plutonium, 'cause obviously it has a pretty bad image
in terms of its use in  nuclear weapons, is that it is what
helped power the astronauts on the moon landings
in the 60s and 70s.
Captions by www.SubPLY.com